first let me start with congratulations
on the movie
uh i i know families and it's going to
be a big hit for disney and
i'm sure people are going to love it um
i'm curious how
what was the genesis of you getting
involved in the project was it something
that you pitched on like
how did you get involved um gill netter
first had the rights to the book
um my producer had done things like life
of pi and the blind side and things like
that
and so he adapted it with a screenwriter
named brad copeland um who had done
things for like arrested development
he recently wrote spies in disguise so
i came on board when he they sent me the
script
and i wasn't necessarily looking i don't
i hadn't watched that many kids movies
and so i watched it i mean i read it and
it had this sort of like that arrested
development humor
it had sort of like the things that like
will make adults laugh and i was like
okay
maybe maybe i could do this and make it
into a family movie um
and what really got me was just sort of
like the deeper themes i would like
didn't shy
away from these adult issues and it hit
very personally for me to have like
something about people who'd sort of
been like i don't know dropped to their
knees by the world and what it takes to
get back up again
and i just love that so much it felt
like it was so much more than just like
a movie
about a family um and i was kind of in
from there we went around pitching to
some of the different studios and
ultimately landed with disney
uh yeah this this feels like a uh
this is definitely a good fit at disney
um the
it's based on a novel uh and obviously
you can't make it exactly like what the
novel is you have to make changes
can you sort of talk about some of the
things that you i guess like you know
balancing that you know keeping the fans
of the novel happy while also
making a movie um from my part
i i purposely didn't read the book until
almost post um obviously the
screenwriter had quite a bit
um and i used it more to inform things
like the voice over this and that
because i wanted to make sure the movie
had its own life and could stand on his
own feet and wasn't constrained like
just whatever
um and my producer was the one who
helped us make we were always
the main themes of the movie and the
main characters came from the book and
that would never change
we made sure to be true to that um
especially about you know her genesis
from being a cynic to somebody who knows
how to see the world
um but beyond that we just kind of took
things and we made like for instance
there's some of the characters that we
tried to make a little
more full formed like for instance the
main one is is
george um in the book he's um he's
really depressed and he's down on his
luck and he doesn't sort of have as much
of that backstory
so ours we wanted to make somebody who
had who didn't know how to kind of see
himself anymore
and now he's uh he's a comic book artist
of his own right
and kind of bringing all that through uh
miller was a creation and then there was
just small things that just made me
excited like
i was trying to figure out how to
replace marianne the shepherdess lamp
which is in the book the lamp is a is
marianne like a shepherdess
and i was like no no we gotta have
something that goes with that whole like
romance novelist thing that'll make
people laugh
and then when i happened upon thinking
of um
jack and rose then i was like yes so it
was a lot of things like that and then
ultimately my producer had to call james
cameron
and get permission for us to use the
jack and rose and that was like a whole
thing
that's a great bit in the movie um have
you seen ex machina
yes okay so when you are filming a dance
sequence in a movie
are you always in the back of your mind
is this ever going to be as cool
as um oscar dancing an ex machina
i don't know if i was thinking exactly
that but yeah maybe something like that
although ben is really charismatic when
he's dancing so we were kind of just
captivated by him and his weird moves
i i completely understand you have um
you start the movie off with a joke
about silver surfer
you show the wolverine mini series comic
book how tough was it to get that stuff
in the movie did you have to jump
through a lot of hoops or did it
actually end up being pretty easy
we had a significant amount of of things
basically
i put as many as i could well what the
goal wasn't to put them in and they just
kind of like
the movie is about like a girl who swims
in this sort of philosophy so they
naturally came through
and then we had to deal with clearances
so we were lucky because by that point
we had already done a couple of
screenings
and so disney was like really happy to
push for us
so they pushed and used their disney
strength
with like i think sean bailey literally
called um
uh kevin feige about to get us to help
us with that intro sequence
because we were so enamored by it we're
like we have to have that um he helped
push that through but there's some
things where like they were like
okay it's a little much now you gotta
stop like at the end on the
main on ends which was one of my
favorite images it was drawn so cool you
have ulysses with an infinity gauntlet
but instead of the
infinity stones there's m ms there was
one where wolf where
ulysses was i had a wolverine post like
he was going like this
except he had like some tree branches
that were caught on his hands
like it happened to me like that they
said we can't do that one either it was
a little little too much
oh the curtain just fell
sorry yeah i was going to say that real
life
yes um so uh in the movie you also you
have a nice doorbell reference with star
wars
uh there's a marvel line that i don't
want to give away that uh from
um tony stark um that kind of stuff was
that also
uh tough to use or was it all in that
whole thing about clearances
that was the same sort of um clearance
clearance thing we had to go with the
the the marble line was fine that one
actually had no problem
um we basically just had to pay for the
one for the doorbell
and we had we had a bunch of ones we
thought of that was the one that i
really wanted because
um george is a little depressed at that
point or maybe a little angry at you so
we wanted something that was
comic nerdy but also had a little
darkness to it and so that's where that
came
um talk a little bit about uh obviously
when you get in the editing room
you're hoping that it's all going to
come together what did you learn from
like your first assembly cut
that made you happy and also made you
nervous the one that made me really
happy was how much ulysses was able to
carry his own
i think that was able to hold his own
and the big thing is
we really had to calibrate phyllis's
character
because she is technically in the book
of villain so we had to kind of make
sure that we were also rooting for her
so i think the most massaging that was
done was on that front
and it was it was also just picking the
things like your battles there was so
much comedy
and they had done so much improv that we
had to make sure they were always just
serving the story
um and pull back you know when we needed
to that's what i was also curious about
when you have a really funny people in
the movie
about imagining that there's going to be
alt takes on almost
everything that you're like i could use
that i could use that or i could use
that
yeah and there's a lot where like me and
let's say you know the writer like we
just loved it we adored it but maybe
like
you know somebody over at disney would
have you know a different take on it so
we'd be doing this like debates all the
time like we were fighting over lines
you know and it was good i think that
things are better for it for the fight
but yeah there's
a lot of debates uh this movie does not
work
without your lead and she is fantastic
um talk a little bit about casting
matilda and
uh when did you know that she was the
one
my um my casting director emily
schweiber
is responsible for the search for
matilda and ultimately finding her
so we sh she showed us we went through
over a thousand girls
and it was really like we just could not
find somebody who
could say like you know these mature
things and where you'd actually believe
she knows what she's saying
and who also could do that vulnerability
because she is at the end of the day
still a 10 year old
and who can do that dry humor like that
fighting humor
and sometimes with the sarcasm and so
she was literally the only one we found
who could do that
and so the first audition we're like
okay maybe first of all her
voice is amazing and then i think i just
needed to get onto skype with her once
and see the way that she also
lit up because she has that like young
juno type quality
but for the movie you also have to make
sure that her optimistic side can come
out too and she can be basically a
little girl and light up
and i saw that on when i skyped with her
and then i think from there i was like
there can be nobody else
in this movie um you have a lot of vfx
shots in this thing
and you had i believe like a year and a
half in post or a year in post
talk a little bit about maybe some of
the shots that were just making you want
to scream
um oh gosh yeah the um the three-point
landing was very important to me like
every time i saw that and it wasn't
exactly what i imagined it to be i was
like no it's not right yet that has to
be the most badass moment of the whole
movie
and then um and the end of the movie uh
that sequence where he's jumping on the
trees and he goes up and it's batman
um that one was dragging me insane too
because first we tried it with plates
that didn't work ultimately that is an
entirely cgi created shot and that means
it took like six months
and you're creating the whole thing out
of like you're just hoping it works even
though you can't even see most of it yet
is it sort of nice to not have to worry
about the opening weekend box office
that it's just going to be out and you
know what i mean yeah
no for sure and i think um there is
something really nice the one that we're
like the one thing about it coming out
during a pandemic
and having like a funny movie that is
literally what people could use right
now
is that there's going to be a lot of
people who will watch it at their house
and so there's something kind of freeing
about that and knowing
that people are looking for content and
they are watching on the platform so
there was something that you know made
us feel good about that completely
listen
congrats on the movie i hope you're
making something else really soon
thank you so much for your time thank
you